good morning today i am taken with two ic i
adore and lucca the first one has rented to
make a video there i only have centers
in the italian language and now the guys
give a demonstration of these
accents thanks thanks for the introduction
then i will call you long in short
generable that is  I like
it since I was little that I
started studying so then it took him to
study the Hebrew brian for seven years
in short, then he left alone that top
100 seconds of us members and social to
start a more normal language
outdated simpler stuff  the
spanish portuguese gives like this and i
continued then i started on the
tracks i resigned and where to study
sure of adorno and roma
as roma but in short high beat but i
'm from grease isolino so and therefore
you are the scum mother madonna who did not
know you know i am  days you play as
he likes because those who leave the class of the
center born of ash music at the
beginning when he spoke to him for the first
time they answered me m  the carry-over of the
brides never understood anything
practically the view this one fatemeh
want an act of where you are exactly
why speak this format 6 jul
what you do pixie lott 18 years
known to the latter instead I did not
understand the spaces of rome they
look less badly holy me  I was
born
if he didn't make history but
sometimes I talk about Italy starting
at 6 and you don't understand why I accept it
every now and then it's funny a little confuses
some knots life looks to say to
each other I'm yes I'm from Rome but I go for  example of
study and all the stars in the end
remain a bit like this
or on doing the same things I
practically more usually than that person
tell you 7 really because let's say that
I could empire that these people
received a colleague when she worked
before practically she danced like this
mature but he feels but he feels that I am
bell never says well not three
a little bit with a little bit is similar to
santa maria capua vetere
because you agree to put  always
the beauty of Italy are not only
the accents but also there is a certain
parochialism join day silvio we were
talking around with a cuddly
thanks for the Neapolitan lesson of the
fact that for example in Italy
there are many different accents but also
within the same region there are
rivalries for example everyone like Calabria
there are some things you like and
some things you like little ones I am more
above every reason
than the other one
no because practically in calabria
league you play  almost blind without
excessive lecce towards the cage as
censured he tried to cosenza we do not
like naples in all of sicily but for
example also the north is the same thing
okay I tell you 100 of the social
ball attack that stands in gloom
in this other one that  1100 czech very
pale everywhere in lazio for
the transfer differences a room other
system thinking it was what they
go so they are there they are gradually if
they are here  elli di cassino this year
as of cassino who will speak so it is not
a colony between rome and naples they are
reaching almost zero
now the country is beautiful Italian is
long beautiful that is so many accents to
so many diversities of 105 actions an
ecological of Italian design when
we are abroad that we all die to death
who knows capitalia
of cosenza catanzaro send
this important thing to the door with a couple of hours that
you are Italian
this is the final message
the Italian curator came only for
nerves the demonstration of the beauty
of diversity  of accents when the
problem, however, perhaps it is not a problem,
beauty however this that when you speak
with a different accent is also a
personality
I speak a Tuscan I think not only of the
chianti senses but that you also change the
gestures in changes the gestures
change the way of  also in way of
thinking and therefore this this variety
of accents also writing languages
e the quotation marks sounds  and meaning but
also experience of so we wanted to give
a small demonstration you can for him he
likes the central also not only
recently a line in short we hope
that seven days
a hug to a completely different hello